my name is Devin Peterson I'm a grad
student a PhD student in the rice lab at
UC Berkeley and today I'm here to talk
about motive formerly called pandas
Andre and how you can accelerate your
pandas workflows by changing one line of
code so get started I'd like to share a
little anecdote
my background is in genomics and
computational biology data science so I
used to build systems for biologists to
extract data or extract value from that
data and learn about their data and
these systems were usually built on big
data ecosystems and so one day I'm
talking with one of my fellow data
scientists and we're talking a bit about
how data science works and so I put down
a few comments from this conversation
here these are what I call comments from
a data scientist who runs production
genomics work was he says data is too
large to be used in pandas as you may
know genomics data is tens of gigabytes
the terabytes but he wants to be able to
interact with his data so the way that
he solves this problem is he ends up
using big data tools to trim down the
data so that he can use pandas to
analyze now this is not what these tools
are intended for but pandas is a great
way of interacting with your data and as
API is actually inherently interactive
so why can't we use the same tools for
kilo and data and megabytes at scale
data as we do for terabyte scale data
and vice versa so let's take a look at
what I call the current data science
landscape we have tools that are good at
megabytes maybe a few gigabytes these
are single node tools this isn't all of
them of course but these are the tools
that are used they've been used for
years they're used in production at many
companies and they're very well
established in fact they're so well
established that these are the tools
that we teach the students actually to
learn takes
so let's look at the other side terabyte
scale data of course this isn't all of
them again but we have these tools that
are all so many of them are used in
production and they end up being they
end up being a bit different than the
megabyte scale tools or the Giga my
scale tools and so there's this
disconnect where I can't use my
megabytes scale tools for terabytes
killed data and when I try to use my big
data tools on a single node it's the
small scale tools actually scale much
better on that single node we get poor
performance with these large scale tools
and so when we look at the current data
science landscape at a terabyte plus a
lot of these new frameworks that are
coming up have new api's these api's are
often sequel like or pandas like and
many of them also support sequel
natively which is a good thing
but many pandas operations are not
covered by sequel we have a whole host
of operations that are linear algebra
operations and in pandas many of these
operations are rather many of these
frameworks also expose distributed
excuse-me distributed computing concepts
to their users these concepts include
partitioning and shuffling things like
that and tuning these is actually
crucial for your performance in fact if
you choose incorrectly and the number of
partitions your performance will be hurt
significant many of these are also too
heavy wait for a good performance at a
smaller scale and a lot of them are
optimized for batching now none of these
really applies to every single one and
all of them have different components of
each of these
[Music]
but a data scientists core goal is to
extract value from data and we're
exposing these distributed computing
concepts to them well what is it about
extracting value from data that actually
requires some expertise and distributed
computing I think nothing
so with Modan we're trying to bridge the
gap between analytics at megabytes scale
and terabytes killed Abel a lot of this
has to do with how we use the API or how
we build our API so modon the tagline is
accelerate your pandas workflows by
changing one line of code
I'm sure you've all been waiting
patiently to find out what this line was
I've I've teased you long enough
it's the import statement so instead of
importing pandas as PD you import mode
and pandas SPD and now you're using all
the cores on your machine to be able to
do your analytics sidebar this was this
is Jupiter slides and this was running a
Jupiter notebook on my desktop at home
it's a little bit old I think that's
okay okay so for starters let's just
build some toy data and play around so
we can import numpy and create this 2d
numpy array pass it to a data frame and
we see even the data frame constructor
is exactly the same I didn't have to
specify partitioning and I can add some
prefix to the columns to make it a
little bit easier to work with things
like this I want to print out the type
it's a mode and data frame so if I were
to print out the first 10 lines with
head we see it renders an HTML table
just like pandas would now this looks a
little bit different than a dozen in
Jupiter itself and pandas has the same
behavior well we'll look later at an
actual notebook but it is literally the
same thing the pandas prints
but with modin we're managing the data
partitioning and shuffling so that you
can focus on extracting value from your
data this is what we believe data
scientists purpose is not focusing on
things like shuffling and partition okay
so let's take a look at read CSV three
CSV is by far the most used pandas
pandas operation I mean it makes sense
right you have to ingest your data
somehow but here I imported pandas so
that we can do a quick comparison and
when we run read CSV on pandas it takes
about 29 and a half seconds on this 800
megabyte data set and with mode and it's
taking 7.6 now remember this is run on
four cores so we get a 4x speed up here
this is actually fantastic but you'll
also notice there's no place to put
partitioning here I don't have to
specify the number of partitions let's
take a look at group by group by the
performance isn't as impressive at first
but pandas group AI is actually
extremely well written and it's actually
extremely performant and when you have
something like Modan which is
distributed across all the cores of your
machine there's a lot of communication
if you know a little bit about how group
is implemented and so even with that
communication overhead on a single node
we're still actually outperforming and
we don't really have a whole lot of
optimizations in the way of group by in
place yet and so I'm actually really
excited about the future of this this is
just basically leveraging all the cores
on your machine so I'm really excited
about group buying the futures group out
so let's take a quick look at transpose
transpose you see here it's extremely
fast at first it's only manipulating
metadata this is kind of the the lazy
idea the lazy operation idea not
everything in modin is lazy yet but when
we take a look at this and we print out
the tail tail takes you know
100 milliseconds or so and you can
operate with it you can operate on this
data frame essentially in real time
interactivity that's really the the core
point of mode button mode and we're
handling all the partitioning and all
the shuffling for you so that you can
focus on just continuing to use your
workflows the goal is to be able to
continue using the same tools that you
are at small data on large data you're
doing the same thing after all it's the
same operations so you have to you
shouldn't have to change your API
whenever you throw it to me that lunch
so how do we get the speed up this is a
modern laptop well let's pretend that
this is what a modern laptop looks like
four cores and a data frame that fits
comfortably in memory let's pretend like
this is our work field for now so with
pandas pandas is only using one of your
CPUs and you have a bunch of idle cores
that are essentially doing nothing with
modon we're actually using all the cores
in machines so we get full utilization
and that helps you be more productive so
let's take a look at a large machine
pandas on a large machine it becomes
much more evident let's pretend like
this is some server or something
so pandas are still only using one core
but moding can still use all of the
cores so a good illustration of this is
a plot that we made I'm fortunate enough
to have access to a machine that has 144
cores and read CSV we see this really
nice linear scaling in pandas but that's
because it's still only using one core
it may be hard to see the bars because
they're so low in mode and but two
gigabytes takes about two seconds 18
gigabytes takes less than 18 seconds so
we get more than a gigabyte per second
on this machine of read-through which is
fantastic
so modon is an early multi excuse me an
early-stage multi-process data frame
library with an identical API to pandas
cluster support is coming soon so talked
about pandas a lot let's dig a little
bit deeper the pandas API is massive
that's a very rich API that's partly why
it's used and it has such such a wide
range of use cases and in many different
industries but if we take a look
data frame 280 plus methods series 280
plus methods other operations like
concatenate
40 plus that's that's a lot of
operations and you might look at me and
say well like how do you even get
started implementing this right where do
you even start how how do you get
started whenever this is such an
overwhelmingly large amount of things
that are need to be implemented so we
took a data-driven approach we actually
took a look at what people use in pandas
we went to cattle and we did a massive
scrape of all the notebooks and scripts
that people use to you know enter
competitions and to play around and
learn and and to instruct even there's a
wide variety of use cases in cattle and
we basically Counting and we figured out
what are the most popular methods and
you can see read CSV of course is by far
the most a lot of actually datasets in
cattle or CSV so that explains part of
that but now that we have this
information we can actually start
implementing things and optimizing them
in the order of their popularity and so
we actually did that so we started with
the most popular methods and we kind of
started working our way down
currently we support about 71% of the
pandas API which represents about 93% of
usage based on our study series is not
yet distributed although you can access
the full API but as we continue
developing this and adding to you know
adding a distributed series we'll be
able to get a lot of optimizations and
things like group by and now you know I
mentioned before all the other
optimizations we can add a group by
we're actually doing group I without a
distributed series without a distributed
1d object so yeah that that actually
should help kind of put those numbers in
context a little bit better multi index
multi index is something that a lot of
people use we have preliminary support
for that it works mostly yeah it should
know it it works a lot of things through
default to pandas and what happens to
the rest though what if what if
something that you use falls in that 30%
well I'm happy to announce this week we
actually implemented something really
nice we can actually default to pandas
so I mentioned this a little bit about
the you know multi index thing multi
index some some operations do default to
pandas and that that's what I meant by
preliminary but let's take a look at how
this works so covariance covariance some
of you may use covariance but in our
study less than half a percent of the
notebooks ended up using it so it falls
fairly low on the on the orders so we
haven't implemented it yet but people
still use it it's useful so we see here
if I do DF Cove we see a warning the
warning says defaulting to pandas
implementation this is how you know that
modon is not working in parallel
essentially so you should expect a
little bit lower performance so when we
do head we see that the covariance was
in fact calculated but it's important to
note that this is a modem data frame and
what we're doing is we're effectively
taking our distributed pet
excuse me our distributive mode and data
frame converting it to pandas performing
the operation on that and then
converting it back
and of course distributed in this case
means multi process it's an overloaded
term I know this but distributed in that
we have partitions and things like this
so now you can do almost anything in
modon that you could normally do in
pandas this is great you can start
trying it out so let's take a look under
the hood
what does Modan look like behind the
scenes I'm gonna go through each of
these individually at the top I've
talked to about a lot of already about
this
the pandas API it's identical to pandas
below that we have a core a compiler
layer and this is the layer where we get
a lot of optimizations when it comes to
you know language specific things memory
specific things we have an in memory
format right now that is pandas and so
we can do a lot of optimizations
understanding basically the in memory
format the petitioner manager layer this
is managing partitioning this is
actually also a very interesting
component of modem because the partition
manager has full control over the size
and shape of the partitions and the
number of partitions you remember I said
we don't expose the number of partitions
to the user that's because in modon we
can actually change the number of
partitions based on the operation we can
alter the shape and size of the
partitions and all this happens because
we don't have this requirement that the
users tell us how many partitions that
we we need to have and so the partition
manager is also in charge of serializing
the query and shipping it off to the
partitions and things like that and then
you know at the lowest layer of course
we have our partitions and you'll notice
that their their partition along two
axes here we have essentially what's
called block partitioning it's not real
level it's not it's not column level
it's actually
along both axes and this gives us a lot
of partitions also or excuse me a lot of
flexibility also the flexibility here is
that we get scalability in both
directions we can also alter the size
and shape of this and the number of
these partitions based on what the
partition manager deems is is best and
so on an extremely high level that is
the guts of motive and you see here
something I haven't mentioned yet is
this this executes Sondre and you're
probably wondering what ray is right now
I mentioned pandas on ray right said
only it only seems fair that I
introduced ray now right so what is ray
Ray's another research project in the
rice lab at UC Berkeley it's a task
parallel system it's a it's an execution
framework essentially tasks parallel
extremely low latency and extremely
highly performance effectively ray has
two main abstractions tasks and actors
tasks are akin to functions that you
would run and you can run them remotely
actors are akin to classes so you can
have some stateful operations and all of
this is built on top of an extremely
high performance back-end written in C++
and you can see on the top there a
number of layer excuse me there are a
number of libraries data processing
that's motive but we have some RL
libraries some hyper parameter tuning
libraries streaming model serving we
have a number of applications that are
being built on top of bread
that's a race core goal is to kind of
unify the ml ecosystem this is a
probably a very overwhelming figure here
essentially what what Modan uses most is
the object store ray exposes a shared
memory object store which makes it
extremely easy to write application code
especially when you need to communicate
between different partitions so ray is
open source you can find it at this URL
and you can also check out their
documentation if you're interested okay
don't wish me luck okay so for this demo
I decided to do something relatively
simple but hopefully it gets the message
across so ten minutes of pandas is the
famous pandas intro just this is
actually on pandas documentation so it
helps you learn pandas so I downloaded
this and converted it to a notebook and
see here I'm gonna run these this is
pandas I don't know what I saw what's
your stuff sometimes that fixes things
ok let's try it out there we go cool
okay so we're gonna import pandas and
we're gonna do go through a bunch of
these things we're gonna create a series
create a data frame create another data
frame you look for D types tail checking
out the contents values describe maybe
getting some summary statistics
transpose
sort sort by index or by values maybe
some selection things perhaps and so
essentially what I'm doing right now is
running pandas and effectively pandas is
running single thread now on this scale
of data it may not make much of a
difference it definitely doesn't but
everything here works great of course it
does it's pandas right okay that's
probably enough for now so let's change
our one line of code okay so this is the
output that happens whenever you run
mode and this is Rea actually giving you
feedback saying things started off okay
[Music]
okay let's try this again
okay
okay so something is up with my Jupiter
session but I guess you'll just have to
take my word for it so effectively yeah
you can put this on one of those demo
blooper reels but effectively what you
would have seen had this worked like it
did ten minutes ago is I changed that
one line of code and then I run through
everything and the output is literally
the same and so it literally is a one
line of code change and you've basically
unlocked all the course of your machine
to use panelist okay so now that our
wonderful demo is over let's start to
wrap up so with Modan you can accelerate
your pandas workflows by changing one
line of code the API is identical to
pandas and you don't need to know
anything about distributed computing to
be able to use it I talked at a really
high level about the architecture and I
also gave a brief introduction to Ray
moving forward there we have a long list
of things this is probably you know a
very small subset of things that we
really want to do with this library but
you know one of the things that we
really care about is memory management
pandas is kind of memory hungry and what
we hope to do is kind of continue
improving on our memory management
ourselves we also want to implement some
out of core memory or out of out of
memory data frames or data frames that
exceed memory query planning there's
always exciting research to be done in
query planning better partitioning
planning more API coverage distributed
panda series I already mentioned that
currently we support the most recent
stable release of pandas API which is
0:23 4 and as as pandas API continues to
change it doesn't change a lot at this
point but I
it continues to change will continue to
change with it we kind of have to pin
ourselves to a specific API if we want
to have the kind of identical behavior
and moanin is only eight months old we
started this around February time and so
as we continued developing this it'll
get more mature if you're interested in
contributing we'd love to have you you
can email the mailing list it's found in
the documentation I'll give you a link
in a moment you can also just go to the
github and pick an issue or you can come
find me wandering around you and with
that I will take any questions yes so
right now it's pretty crude and pretty
early most of the work is planned in
that space perhaps it could end up being
a contribution Japan is also a lot of
the work that we're doing here could end
up eventually being contributed
dependents definitely we built a system
to kind of solve this problem of
interactivity and query planning is an
important part of that but when you do
query planning on a system that's
intended for interactivity you really
have to be careful about how much time
you're wasting of the users so to put
this in perspective I spent a long time
doing doing research in like
applications built on top of spark and
spark is lazy and when I interact with
spark sometimes I don't get error
messages until the end of my script but
the error happened on line 2 or 3 so
really what we're interested in with
query planning is making sure that we we
give fast results to the user because
interactivity is kind of the key
if that make sense did I answer your
question well so so right now so you
want like real details right now yeah
sure yeah find me afterward definitely
yes in the back yes yes yes yes and a
lot of the time it's not possible to do
that what machine because I'm going to
kind of address that like this
large-scale data manipulations good
question good question
so the question was is modem gonna stay
on one machine or are we going to be
able to actually scale to terabyte scale
the short answer is we're going to be
able to scale the mode it actually
already works on a cluster the the one
line of code changed though is not so
easy when you have to set up the cluster
so we're working on scripts right now to
kind of make that easier Rea what it's
built on runs in a cluster without
problems and and since we're built on
top of that there are really no issues
with with running on the cluster so so
effectively right now all we support is
the pandas API panas has a way for
reading from sequels so it's not like
some of those components like like
reading from a file and data interest
and things like that some of them are
distributed yet but you know in the
future we definitely are
that data injustice you know one of the
most challenging parts of using patterns
so exciting answer your question yes
this is a young project meaning in terms
of scaling up interactivity pandas
typically you have nested ten times the
amount of memory to their dates in size
just for its occasional extra copies and
ramp-up sarcasting and have you
addressed any of that or is it
fundamentally still similar like if you
want to play with it
everybody exciting they meet up before
tear by a terabyte machine yeah good
question so the question is do we
actually address the problem in pandas
of memory consumption because pandas
requires 8 to 10 X the the memory cost
and to answer your question we've
started to solve this problem the there
are a lot of challenges here because
just of that because of the nature of
pandas API and and the nature of these
like single point updates and things
like that it's something that we're
continuing to work on and that is also a
pain point with with pandas that we that
we want to continue does that answer
your question
yes in the back so yeah the question is
can I compare with desk
in what respect like like I see ok so
how does this compare with desk data
frame as the question so that's data
frame it exposes a subset of the pandas
API and it's also lazy so you put in
these dot computes everywhere when you
want to trigger execution it doesn't
have the exact same output as pandas for
every single operation if I if I were to
go to this the demo that you know didn't
work so well but if I were to try to run
through run through some of those
operations in ten minutes to pandas it
will start breaking around I look
because because they don't support ila
and so the API is different but but
fundamentally modin is actually like
basque could end up being a back end
right now we run Andre but but the
purpose of modon is kind of to be a
dataframe library where you can kind of
just run it on whatever you have I
didn't really get into that but
generally you know I think the goals
with that data frame are a bit different
than the goals with Mona does that
answer your question okay
I mean do you have do you have a
follow-up question that you want to
clarify sorry how are they how are they
different
sure yeah and and desk does scale beyond
a single machine so I mean I kind of
answered the question already related to
like the API right fundamentally the
architectures are very different Basque
desk is partitioning things along rows
and moden is partitioning them along
both axes that gives us the power to be
able to support the full pandas API
whereas you know that would require some
so a lot of effort like you can consider
doing a transpose in a system like tasks
you have to do all the all shuffling all
- all communication and it's extremely
inefficient so designers your question
nuts okay any other questions yes yeah
great so the question is what are our
plans for dealing with larger than
memory data so modin is built on top of
Ray and Ray uses the arrows plasma store
as its back-end in the plasma store with
with the plasma store we can actually
use the disk as a as a back-end
for for the for the actual plasma story
I played around with this you can
actually scale beyond beyond your memory
with this there's just some performance
things that we want to tune a little bit
before we actually start exposing this
so essentially though using the disk as
a back-end for your for your memory and
using it that way especially if you
don't have 50 gigabytes of memory or you
would have to have a little bit yeah
yeah yeah so it would not work on the
current master definitely so so we don't
expose it yet basically the the kind of
disk backed data frames that makes sense
but in the future I mean it's it's not
something that that will take a lot more
effort just because of the really nice
abstractions we get from Ray and arrow
so okay any other questions yes where
does it break most often this is a good
question well the demo was supposed to
work that's not that's not where it
normally breaks this is this is the
nature and the risk you take with land
ions is the thing they can just get like
I I think it's my Jupiter environment
honestly yeah but where it breaks most
often is with indexing so we we store
the index separately as an optimization
so that we keep the memory inside the
partitions small and we just keep like a
numerical index you know inside the
partitions and if if we've written bad
code
effectively or if if something ends up
going wrong usually it ends up
presenting itself as an index mismatch
effectively so that's that's kind of
where things break most is with with the
indexing okay
we're to start debugging and in modon or
in your own yeah index indexing indexing
is something that we're always working
on effectively and yeah that's normally
how how issues present themselves
normally it ends up with like some kind
of like we're not we're not effectively
communicating the right amount of data
or the right data from the partitions to
the actual index object and so that's
that's where things kind of get
misaligned if that makes sense
any other questions okay thank you
[Applause]